hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Martin Heidegger is lecture what is
metaphysics takes its fundamental
orientation from a particular
philosophical and metaphysical problem
what he calls the question of the
nothing determining what the nothing is
or isn't and you might say well that's
not a problem at all we already know
ahead of time that there isn't anything
that comes from nothing and nothing
really isn't something and and Heidegger
would say that's nice you managed to
replicate what goes on in you know sort
of Christian and post Christian
metaphysical schemes but is that really
the case we're engaged in fundamental
metaphysical inquiry we want to approach
the nothing and see what we can make of
it now immediately at the beginning of
the essay Heidegger is going to tell us
that our existence is contemporary
modern is determined is is conditioned
it takes its orientation fundamentally
from what he's terming here science or
the sciences you might say not just the
scientific method or you know what we
reconstruct of what scientists do but
the entire panoply of you might say
trusting in science and technology is an
overarching way of understanding matters
and understanding the universe and he
goes on and he tells us a few
interesting things here he talks about
the sciences the scientific field as
being diverse there are a multiplicity
he says the ways they treat their
objects of inquiry differ fundamentally
why why is that well because they are
approaching different kinds of beings as
hiders going to say different objects
the scientists themselves might say so
for example chemistry and biology share
a lot in common enough so that there's
actually you know organic chemistry and
you know divide sort of not quite six
dividing line between that and things
dealing
with life and when we can have all sorts
of interesting hybrid Sciences we're
blending sciences together but you know
insofar as something is considered
scientific it's not necessarily because
it follows some sort of you know writ on
large scientific method each different
discipline has its own particular ways
of doing things understanding things
teaching things standards they do share
some things in common but they often
have a lot that that's separating them
it's also important to point out to that
that for Heidegger science is this and
shaft it's a term that has a bit of a
wider application in in German then the
term science by itself does in English
French also has something similar you
know and there's a distinction between
for example the Natural Sciences and the
human sciences so you know we have a lot
of what we call social sciences and you
might say well what is what's different
in that compared to say the theorization
that takes place in philosophy sometimes
the answer is not all that much it
depends on how things are being
conceived but Heidegger says that the
ways in which they treat their objects
of inquiry differ fundamentally so
fundamentally that as he points out only
the fact of having universities helps to
hold all these Sciences together we
might think in our own time not just of
universities but also of various think
tanks and research groups and
corporations that are carrying out
research those those assure a kind of
continuity to the notion of science he
says only the technical organisation of
universities and faculties consolidates
this burgeoning multiplicity of
disciplines the practical establishment
of goals by each discipline provides the
only meaningful source of unity and then
he points out something very important
there the way he puts it is not that
they aren't completely rooted at all in
their essential ground but that it is
atrophied the the routing
in their essential ground whatever that
happens to be in something that
transcends the sciences themselves and
give them their teleology their purpose
their orientation that has atrophied and
so often science is being done for its
own sake or it becomes instrumentalized
not an issue that he talks about here
but something that he talks about in
many other places now what is
fundamental about this Heidegger says we
want to look at what's really core to
science in terms of metaphysics so he
tells us in the sciences we relate to
beings themselves as they are that's the
promise of science he also is a really
interesting discussion here of exactness
that I'm going to skip over a little bit
very similar to that in Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics where he
distinguishes between the exactness and
say mathematics and that of other
disciplines like say FX or Heidegger
we'll have here historiographical work
now he says the sciences approach what
is essential in all being this is what
is viewed as being essential to science
not the the issue of exactness but that
they get at the beings themselves and
what is essential to them so he says
this distinctive relation to the world
in which we turn towards beings is
supported and guided by a freely chosen
attitude of human existence so this is
very important there's there's a world
that's part of what science is examining
it turns to the world and tries to let
the things themselves reveal themselves
to us oftentimes coercing them into
doing so or carrying out a lot of
interesting experiments on them but by
being attentive to them and that
requires on the part of the scientist or
the person who is engaging in science is
an activity a certain attitude towards
those beings that will allow this to to
occur so he says here we go
it's a freely chosen attitude of human
existence now Heidegger says to be sure
man's pre-scientific and extra
scientific activities are also related
to
beings so the arts culture all of that
sort of thing is also ways in which we
relate ourselves to being science is not
the only manner of approaching beings
but there's something that we we moderns
tend to to ascribe to science
he said science is exceptional in that
in a way peculiar to it it gives the
matter itself explicitly and solely the
first and last word so there's supposed
to be an impartiality of enquiring
determining and grounding he said this
is a submission to being themselves and
why in order that the beings may reveal
themselves this is where the emphasis on
say objectivity comes in and the
reproducibility of experiments that is
so key in in the whole ideological
apparatus of science the story that it
tells itself about itself or rather the
story that we human beings tell
ourselves about our activity science
through that that activity itself and
through the institution's we build up
around it all these other things that
are rolled into it Heidegger is really
putting his finger on something
essential here and he's not just setting
science up to knock it down he is saying
what is actually best in the sciences at
this point so he says going on this
position of service in research and
theory evolves in such a way as to
become the ground of the possibility of
a proper though limited leadership in
the whole of human existence science in
the modern era can play a major role
within our organization within the ways
in which we understand ourselves in
which the ways in which we make
decisions about medicine about city
planning about politics itself so he
goes on and he says the special relation
science sustains to the world and the
attitude of man that guides it can only
be grasped fully when we see and
comprehend what happens in the relation
of the world
so a teamed human beings or man one
being among them pursues science and the
question then was what is happening when
we pursue science the way that Heidegger
describes this he says nothing less
transpires than the eruption by one
being called man into the whole of
beings indeed in such a way that in and
through this eruption beings break open
and show what they are and how they are
this breaks open helps beings above all
to themselves so this is actually again
a very you know positive view of what it
is that science does what does science -
science is one way in which we to use
another high daguerreian phrase let
beings be and allow them to show
themselves to us there's so many things
that we did not know about the world
that have been revealed to us through
the Natural Sciences there are so many
things about us as as beings in the
world that had been revealed to us
through the social sciences and for
Heidegger that would also include his
you know history itself and some other
disciplines that tell us about the kind
of being that we are now Wyatt why is
this a problem well it's not the problem
the problem is what got left out so he
says this Trinity relation of the world
the attitude and eruption brings a
luminous simplicity and aptness of
design to scientific existence and here
he starts getting us to the point of
talking about the nothing if we are to
take explicit possession he says of the
design the way of existing the the being
that is existing illuminated for
ourselves then we have to say three
things that to which the relation of the
world refers are being themselves and
nothing besides that from which every
attitude takes its guidance are being
themselves and nothing further
that which with the scientific
confrontation in the eruption occurs are
being themselves and beyond that nothing
now notice that in each of these cases
he
ended what he's saying by introducing a
nothing is this wasted words is this
just him
closing off a sentence with a kind of
parallelism that allows you know maybe a
flourish at the podium No
Heidegger thinks that there is a nothing
that has been ignored by science so this
is where it starts to become quite
tricky he says what is remarkable is
that the way that scientific man secures
to himself was most properly his he
speaks of something different what
should be examined are beings only and
beyond that nothing beings alone and
further nothing solely beings and beyond
that nothing so there's nothing is kind
of haunting the beings that science is
is treating this nothing is not being
thematized by the science so he says
well what about this nothing is it an
accident that we talk this way so
automatically is it only a matter of
speaking and nothing besides notice that
he's already doing the same thing
bringing in the nothing again at this
point and he says well what do we what
trouble do we take concerning there's
nothing then nothing is rejected by
science given up as a nullity it's sort
of stripped off we don't have to worry
about that Heidegger wants to look at
the nothing and this is an interesting
point this is where you know quite often
philosophy is going to differ from the
sciences by asking the questions that
the scientists are not interested in
asking and will tell you we don't ask
that sort of thing here get the hell out
of here go down to the philosophy
department which is how some people get
their start in philosophy now how could
we elaborate this question as Heidegger
said here is where we have to turn to
the question of logic
Heidegger is not going to go as far into
this as he does in some other works but
he is grayness tell us that so the
sciences are supposed to be ultimately
resting on some conception of logic and
something like the normative laws of
thought that govern everything
inescapable somehow they are not only
governing our thought but also being
itself and that is something we can't
get away from and logic is not going to
allow us to grapple with nothing in the
way that Heidegger really wants to it is
going to have an answer about the
nothing but in a sense it's the wrong
answer so Heidegger goes on and he says
what is the nothing our first approach
to this question has something unusual
about it in our asking we posit the
nothing in advance is something that is
such-and-such we posit it as a being and
he says we can't do that that's not
going to work
that is exactly what its distinguished
from so if we take that sort of approach
we won't attain anything and then he
says it's not Sciences rejection that
first of all teaches us this the
commonly cited ground rule of all
thinking the proposition that
contradiction is to be avoided universal
logic itself lays low the question of
the nothing if we're trying to frame the
nothing as something so he says thinking
which is always essentially thinking
about something must act in a way
contrary to its own essence when it
thinks of the nothing
it has to stretch itself in such a way
as to do what it is is not what its job
is and so he says have we arrived at the
end of our inquiry assuming that in this
question logic is of supreme importance
that the intellect is the means and
thought the way to conceive the nothing
originally and decide about its possible
exposure so here why is he talking about
logic at this point and the intellect
one way of approaching the nothing is
precisely to try to go deeper to go into
the very foundation of things and we
often think that we do so by getting to
logic and by using the intellect and by
thought thinking about itself when we do
that we arrive at a formulation of the
nothing that Heidegger says
a mistaken one namely that nothing is
the negation of the totality of beings
now what does that mean that means think
about everything and now think about not
that think as many things as you like
now think about the negation of those
negate each one let's take it a very
concrete example think about me dr.
Sadler in front of you now take away my
voice maybe you do this by turning off
the sound do that the second time around
right
and now imagine my glasses gone and my
hair gone and my tie gone and my shirt
gone and everything else about me gone
as well you're negating me don't just
take you know remove all the clothes
because then you just got a naked me
standing here and that's still a me
negate the whole whole thing the whole
package and negate the chalkboard negate
everything that you're seeing through
there
and now you've got an idea about what
what Heidegger is talking about negate
the totality of beings and you're left
with nothing
what this means is that nothing would be
essentially dependent upon this
operation of negation carried out by the
intellect Heidegger wants to suggest to
us that the relationship between nothing
and negation is actually the opposite
that negation derives fundamentally from
the nothing and that logic in the
intellect is not our primary motive
access to the nothing that is or isn't
the nothing that nothing's to use that
phrase that got the attention and ire of
the logical positivists that is the
approach that he's going to take and so
what does this mean that the science is
as great as they are have left something
out that they themselves cannot
take account of metaphysics is going to
be required in order to get us there
you